داخل التحكم في المهمة في
قاعدة باكلي للقوة الفضائية في أورورا كولورادو ،
حراس قوة الفضاء كما يُعرفون ، يطيرون
أقمار الإنذار الصاروخي للأمة
باستخدام مستشعرات الأشعة تحت الحمراء ، هذه الأقمار الصناعية التي
تدور حول 22000 ميل فوق الأرض
تنظف الكوكب 24 7 لإطلاق الصواريخ
والتفجيرات النووية التي لا نتوقف عنها أبدًا
متيقظ دائمًا ولم نفشل أبدًا لأن
هذا هو مدى أهمية هذه المهمة
لأمتنا ، فنحن نقدم بيانات جودة القرار
لرجال الحرب التكتيكيين على
الأرض لإنقاذ حياتهم ، إن
طبق القمر الصناعي هذا على اتصال
بأقمار التحذير من الصواريخ المنتشرة في
ما يعرف باسم المدار المتزامن مع الأرض  إذا
اكتشفت أقمار التحذير تلك إطلاقًا في
أي مكان على سطح الكوكب ، فإنها
ترسل تلك المعلومات إلى هذه المحطة الأرضية على الفور بسرعة الضوء ، ثم ترسل قوة الفضاء تلك المعلومات التي تحذر
حول العالم إلى القوات الأمريكية المنتشرة في
الخارج أو هنا على  الوطن الأمريكي في
يناير 2020 انطلقت هذه الأقمار الصناعية
حيز التنفيذ det  استهداف صواريخ متعددة
من إيران استهدفت قاعدة الأسد الجوية
في العراق قبل أن تتساقط تلك
الصواريخ في غضون دقائق ، وجهت القوة الفضائية
تحذيرًا منقذًا
للحياة لوحداتنا على الأرض ،
المتخصصة في القوات الفضائية ، كانت سالي ستيفنز
تعمل بسرعة البرق.
سريعًا بما
يكفي لاتخاذ إجراءات لحماية
أنفسهم تمامًا خاصةً
في ليلة الأسد ، وفي كثير من الأحيان لا
يتم تذكيرنا بالمكان الذي تصل إليه بياناتنا
، وكانت تلك الليلة عبارة عن صاروخ واقعي صادم
أقمار التحذير من الصواريخ ليست سوى
جزء بسيط من المئات  منا
أقمار صناعية حكومية وتجارية تم
رصدها والدفاع عنها من قبل
حراس القوة الفضائية التي دافعت عنها اليوم
لأن أعداءنا بقيادة
روسيا والصين نشروا أسلحة
لتعطيلهم أو تدميرهم. القوة الفضائية هي
الآن فرع مستقل من
الجيش الأمريكي بسبب هذا الجديد المقلق
مساحة الواقع التي كانت ذات يوم منطقة سلمية نسبيًا
تعتبر الآن جبهة محتملة
في أي مساحة حرب حديثة هي معركة
حربية  إن المجال هو السبب في
أننا دافعنا عن قوة الفضاء الأمريكية
كخدمة منفصلة ، لذلك
نقوم كل يوم بتدريب مشغلينا
لردع الصراع ، ولكن إذا
فشل الردع في المنافسة والفوز في الفضاء ، فإن
لدينا أقمار صناعية أكثر بكثير من أي
دولة أخرى حوالي 2500 مقارنة بـ
431 للصين و 168 لروسيا
ومجموعة كاملة من التقنيات العسكرية الأمريكية
تعتمد عليها.
يساعد تشغيل خط القمم المقاتلين الحربيين في
مراقبة التهديدات على البر والبحر وفي
الجو ،
لا يوجد شيء نفعله كقوة مشتركة
سواء كانت المساعدة الإنسانية
الإغاثة في حالات الكوارث أو القتال الذي لم يتم
تمكينه بواسطة الفضاء أكثر مما يدرك العديد من
الأمريكيين أن التقنيات المدنية
تعتمد بشكل متساوٍ على  الفضاء
كوكبة الأمة من الأقمار الصناعية GPS
التي حلقت بواسطة سرب العمليات الفضائية الثانية
في تريفور الفضاء f  قاعدة orce في
كولورادو سبرينغز هي العمود الفقري
للعديد من البنى التحتية الحيوية ، من
المحتمل أن يستخدم الأمريكيون القياسيون
مساحة 20 إلى 30 مرة بين
اللحظة التي يصلون فيها إلى لحظة تناولهم
وجبة الإفطار ، وتعتمد القطاعات المالية
على معلومات تحديد المواقع
والتوقيت لإجراء عمليات ومعاملات مصرفية دقيقة
يعتمد قطاع النقل لدينا لتحديد المواقع وتوقيت خطوط الطيران ج وتعتمد جميعها على نظام تحديد المواقع العالمي
لتكون قادرًا على تنفيذ بنيتنا
التحتية الحيوية ، فإن مهمة
الدفاع عن ما يقرب من ثلاثين من الأقمار الصناعية لنظام تحديد المواقع العالمي (GPS)
تقع على عاتق فريق صغير بشكل ملحوظ من
عشرة أوصياء في الخدمة في أي وقت
يفوق عددهم  ما يقرب من ثلاثة إلى واحد
ونصف المليار دولار من الأقمار الصناعية التي تطير بها
قاعدة القوة الفضائية تريفور تتحكم في
مجموعات متعددة من
الأقمار الصناعية كل كوكبة مع
عشرات الأقمار الصناعية الفردية التي توفر كل منها
إمكانات مثل
الاتصالات العسكرية الآمنة بنظام تحديد المواقع العالمي
والمزيد والمزيد من الوعي الظرفي في الفضاء
وهذا هو  حفظ أ  عين على الأعداء
والأسلحة التي تستهدف أصولنا الفضائية ،
فإن الخطر بالنسبة لنا هو أن
الاعتماد الأكبر على الفضاء
يعني المزيد من التعرض للهجمات
في الفضاء عندما تكون في صدارة
الهدف على ظهرك.
تصارع الأسلحة القادرة على انتزاع
الأقمار الصناعية من مدار روسيا
تنشر أقمار كاميكازي قادرة على
صدم وتدمير أصولنا الفضائية
، ولدى روسيا الآن سلاح فضائي جديد
تطلقه القوات الفضائية على دمية التعشيش
في عام 2017 ، وأطلقت روسيا
قمرًا صناعيًا وفتحت وأخرى
خرج قمر صناعي
ثم انفتح
وخرج مقذوف مصمم
لقتل الأقمار الصناعية ، لذا في عام 2019
فعلوا نفس الشيء ولكن هذه المرة
وضعوه بجانب أحد أقمارنا
الصناعية ثم
بدأنا نتحدث عنها أنت
حذرناهم بعيدًا وصفنا ما هو آمن من
السلوك المهني ومن المهم اليوم
أنه لا توجد قواعد في الفضاء
الغرب
المتوحش لروسيا والصين أيضًا وجهتا
أسلحة طاقة يمكن أن تلحق الضرر
بالأقمار الصناعية لنا أو تعطلها من مسافة بعيدة
، لقد وصل عصر الليزر في الفضاء بالفعل
، يجري تصميم أقمار صناعية جديدة تتمتع
بقدرة أكبر على
المناورة لمنع أسلحة الطاقة الموجهة
والمرونة بحيث تفقد
أحدها  أو عدد قليل منها
لا يعطل النظام بأكمله ،
ثمانية من
قادة القوات الفضائية السبعة رحبوا
بدخول القطاع الخاص إلى الفضاء
لأنه يوفر خيارات أكثر وأرخص
للدخول إلى
المدار يونيو هذا العام ، صُنع أحدث
قمر صناعي GPS على صاروخ سبيس إكس
الذي سأراهن عليه  الصناعة في أي يوم ، إنها
ميزة كبيرة أن لدينا بالنسبة لنا ، بالنسبة
لقوة الفضاء الأمريكية التي تقوم بتسليح وتريد
تجنب سباق التسلح في الفضاء ، فإن الأسلحة هي
الملاذ الأخير من منظور الولايات المتحدة ، فنحن
نفضل أن يظل المجال خاليًا
من الصراع
ولكن كما هو الحال في أي مجال آخر مثل  الجو
والبحر
أو الفضاء الآن سنكون جاهزين
لحماية والدفاع عن الأعداء الذين
حاولوا بالفعل استخدام أسلحة الفضاء
ر  o تعطيل الأقمار الصناعية الأمريكية مؤقتًا
حرب الفضاء ليست خيالًا علميًا ولكنها
معركة جارية بالفعل